there are only a few people in the world
who can say that they have made a
success
out of failing sunil gupta is one of
those people
the only person to ever be invited twice
to fail khan the author of backable
and a serial entrepreneur we sat down
and talked about the importance
of failing and the lessons we can learn
this is a bit of optimism
so here's what i wanted to talk to you
about you
teach innovation which is a whole
another topic whether innovation can be
taught but that we
will table that one um for all intents
and purposes
you teach innovation and i know part of
what goes with innovation is failure
and that you have to fail to innovate
because it's an iterative process
we have raised a generation of kids
it seems that are afraid
of failing if there's a group of people
coming up through school
who are working very hard afraid of
failure afraid of looking bad all the
things and i think that's probably you
could say that for a lot of young kids
but it's a very high performing
young generation we have for the past
probably 20 years so 30 years
and then they hit the real world and
i've experienced this firsthand
and for the first time in their lives
things aren't going according to plan
their parents can't really
fix it so riddle me this
how do you teach failure and the
importance of failure
to people who are now young adults who
may have not
worked that muscle well i think it
begins
by being open about your own failures
and it was interesting for me to
to get a call from harvard med school
saying hey would you like to teach this
subject because
i wasn't smart enough to get into
harvard and i wasn't smart enough to get
into medical school
and one of the things that sort of drew
them to me was this
article that was published years ago on
failure and i'll tell you the story i
get a phone call this is after
two of my startups have failed uh after
you know i've gone through ups and downs
in my career
more downs than ups and i get asked to
keynote
this conference called fail con which
stands for failure conference
and it's this kick me while i'm down
moment because i get this phone call
saying hey we're organizing this
conference on failure and we would love
for
you to be the keynote speaker and so i
do
and i didn't know that there was a
reporter from the new york times in the
audience
and fast forward to a full-length
article on failure with my
face as the cover of this article and
you know it is it is an article also
that goes very viral
you could have googled failure at that
time and
my face would have been one of your top
search results
what ended up happening actually was i
had a conversation with a with a friend
of mine who i grew up with outside of
detroit
we used to go to temple together and he
reminded me of a story
that we were told as kids and it was it
was a story that the buddha
told his disciples which is that every
time you know someone feels pain
there are two arrows that are fired one
arrow is the arrow that punctures your
skin
and the other arrow is the arrow where
you ascribe meaning to the pain
so how are you going to find some
meaning out of this was what he
challenged me to do
and the way that i i tried to do that is
by emailing
basically everybody that i admired and
and i would email them
the article proactively and i would say
in the email listen as you can see
from this article i don't know what i'm
doing but would you be willing to grab
coffee
grab a phone call and the response rate
to that email was
insanely high but more importantly the
conversations
were honest because it wasn't like the
classic networking hey help me succeed
conversation was like i'm here's my
string of failures i'm putting it out in
the open
and as it turns out they would share
their string of failures
and so i think it begins with that
cracking this nut that i think we always
knew was true which is that the version
of the people that we admire
today is not the version that they
started out as there were mistakes there
were setbacks there were failures and i
think as long as we can put those into
domain over and over again
we start to realize that we can do it
too i would argue though that you had
one
massive huge advantage over the rest of
the world
which is your mother your mother
couldn't be overprotective
she taught you resilience because of her
experience
i mean mom's story is incredible it's
what drove me to write
my book it's it's what i think still
fuels me every day
uh as a father as a as a um as an
entrepreneur
mom grew up in a refugee camp on the
border of pakistan
and india no running water no
electricity
but she did something really amazing she
she taught herself how to read
and the first book that she read from
cover to cover was the biography of
henry ford
and after reading this biography she
tells herself and everybody around her i
want to be an engineer
with ford motor company this is her
vision it's it's unlikely if not
impossible but
her parents get behind the dream they
get behind the vision they they save
every penny or rupee they had she gets
on a boat
gets to the united states ends up
getting a scholarship to oklahoma state
university
of all places graduates as the only
female in her engineering class
the next day drives to detroit michigan
to apply for her dream job
finds her way somehow into a room with a
hiring manager at ford motor company
and this hiring manager looks at her
resume and he looks at her
application and he says wait a second
are you applying for the job
of an engineer and she says yeah
and he says well i'm sorry you know we
actually don't have any female engineers
working here right now
because this is the 1960s and ford motor
company by the way is in its heyday like
it's doing very well
they have thousands upon thousands of
engineers on staff but not a single one
of them is a woman
and so in this moment you know my mom is
is
deflated she picks up her resume she
picks up her purse and she begins to
walk out of the room and then almost
like in this last ditch moment she turns
around she looks this guy in the eye
and she tells him her story about all
the struggle about all the sacrifice
that it took for her to get to this
country to get to detroit
to get to this very room and then she
says to him look things are changing
and if you don't have any female
engineers on staff then do yourself a
favor
and hire me now this guy is so moved in
this meeting
that he decides to leave and go fight
with his colleagues
he'll fight with everybody around him to
make this happen
and in 1967 she becomes ford motor
company's first
female engineer amazing so that dream
and that story served your mother
but you grew up in the united states
of a mother who was an engineer at ford
motor company
yeah and so you didn't grow up without
running water
etc so you didn't have to teach yourself
how to read and yet your mother
somehow taught you
perseverance and grit and how to endure
failure
can you tell me some of the specific
things that she did tell me one story
of something specific she did that you
know she drilled into you she parented
you differently than the other kids in
your school
look there there is one there is one
thing and it's a decision simon that
that i think my mom made
and the decision that she made or pretty
early on is that we were
you know i was born in a town called
livonia and we were
we had outgrown the house when i was
born and we
we wanted to make a move and there was a
decision that they had made and the
decision was do we move to a place do we
move to a town
where there are a lot of indian people
because there was such a town
most the indian folks that we knew were
congregating in sort of like
the bloomfield hills farmington sort of
area but there was a
new town called novi which didn't have
very many indian people at all in fact
we didn't know any
and my mom
was the one that pushed for us to go to
novi
for us to go to the all-white community
and there were a lot of times when
sanjay my brother and i would would ask
her like why the hell did you do this
like we're getting picked on all the
time in school we're getting bullied
all the time and our answer was look you
got to learn how to deal with that now
like you got to learn how to figure this
out because
if you don't then you know you're going
to grow up
always wanting to sort of comfort
yourself with people who look just like
you and that's just not the way that the
world works
so i think that's an example of the way
that i think she liked to parent which
is i think in some ways just like throw
us in the deep end yeah
though it makes sense you know take your
kids to a place where they're going to
be uncomfortable
and teach them to endure discomfort
because that's the real world
that bit of parenting is horrific
for a modern parent to choose to take
your kid to a place where they're more
likely to get bullied so that the kid
can learn
to endure difficulty i don't know if a
modern parent can do that
would do that you know the the stories
of richard branson his mom dropping him
off three miles away from
home and saying see you when you get
home so he can learn to find his way
home
well look what that did it it made him
one of the great problem solvers one of
the great entrepreneurs
yeah but you know this is the question
which is in our very
sincere desire to protect our children
have we accidentally over indexed into
the over cuddle
and and now the thought of throwing our
kids in the deep end
is just not on we there is no more deep
end the whole pool is shallow end i
think there's a lot of truth to that
are you as intense as your mom and how
you're raising your kids to deal with
struggle and discomfort or do you find
yourself sort of like sliding into the
modern
philosophies of parenting i find myself
sliding into the modern philosophies of
parenting
yeah no doubt about that i do think that
my job in a lot of ways is to be this
conduit
for her energy how do i let that sort of
come through
i don't quite know how to do that i i
every morning i play this little game
with my daughters i ask them two
questions
i ask them what is the meaning of life
and they say
to find your gift and then i say well
what is the purpose of life
and they say to give it away meaning of
life is to find your gift purpose is to
give it away it's my favorite quote from
picasso
and sometimes i wonder whether i'm doing
enough
to give them the grit that it would take
to do that
right it's nice to have sort of a punch
line it's nice to have a phrase
but am i sort of showing them what it
would take to sort of get to that point
have you noticed a difference in the
first cadre of students you had to the
current cadre
in the way they approach risk i think
that
there have been more stories out there
now than there were
even five years ago of people who have
hit it big out the gate
and i don't know whether that's a good
thing or not
like i think five years ago it was still
facebook it was still snapchat but there
weren't like this long tale of
stories of people who just like hit hit
hit hit
and that i think has sort of given
people in
some ways more confidence but i think in
other ways it has made it look
easy right and and again it comes back
to those stories of
of failure i used to have this slide
that i would put up during my lectures
which would show
the paths of people like richard branson
the paths of people like elon musk
that they had actually they had actually
failed multiple times
before they actually got their first hit
i don't necessarily have
as many of those stories right now for
some of the younger entrepreneurs
and i'm not saying that like we should
have more of those like good for them
for for having quick success but i think
it also might set sort of a bit
a bit of a bad precedent that like hey
it's easy and so i think my job in some
ways
is to is to retain optimism right as as
you do but at the same time
you know let them know that hey like if
it doesn't happen right away that that's
just
that's just a stepping stone to to the
next thing yeah i hear you and i agree
with you and
the problem is talk is cheap right like
we can sit here and say you know failure
is a really important part but the
problem is
is there's now this unrealistic
expectation and there's still millions
and millions and millions of businesses
that are started and exist small
businesses
the vast majority will fail in the first
three years
and the ones that we celebrate and put
the cover in magazines and we know the
names of the companies and sometimes the
ceos celebrity ceos
is they did become 20 something year old
billionaires and now
everyone who starts a startup thinks you
know i'm five years away from being a
billionaire
right and one of the things i think they
completely miss
is that in every case they became
billionaires by accident
they were driven by something else and
the money came afterwards
it was an unintended byproduct even if
they lose sight of what they
were doing in the first place and became
money obsessed later
the trajectory was very different and so
it raises an interesting question which
is a generation
that's growing up with unrealistic
expectations of what it takes to succeed
and even more unrealistic expectations
of what success even means
you know if you can make a few hundred
thousand dollars a year like you are
blowing the doors off
compared to the vast majority of
americans whether you own your own small
business or not millions is
rough and billions as damn near
impossible i have not met a company i
have not met a founder
yet who set out to become a unicorn that
became a unicorn right right like that
was the best exactly right
exactly right this idea of what actually
sort of makes
you tick like what actually makes you
come alive and i know again that's we're
getting back to catchphrases here but
bear with me for a moment because i i
think back to the first time that i'll
be the name of our episode
it'll be catchphrases with sunil gupta
or bear with me for a moment yeah
but i remember having left groupon and i
had been a groupon early and groupon
became
you know quote unquote a unicorn
although it had had massive ups and
downs
and i remember leaving and knowing that
i wanted to go start a company
what i did was this is classic almost
business school analysis i had this
spreadsheet i had columns i had column a
was the ideas but in column c was a
competition
market size et cetera et cetera et
cetera and i remember going to a mentor
of mine and asking her like hey what do
you think like what do you think of
these ideas which which stand out to you
and she looks at the list and then she
looks at me and she's like
let me ask you a question which of these
ideas
actually makes you come alive and i look
back at the list and i realize like
none of them really made me come alive
but sunil these were your tickets
to fame and stardom and unicorn this
exactly
the story that she told me which i
continue to love you've probably heard
this one before
which is that when martin luther king
was really stepping into his
leadership role i always forget how
young he was he's
in his twenties and he went to go see a
a mentor of his guy named howard thurman
and you know he was trying to he's
trying to sort of figure out what steps
he should make whether he should do this
and howard thurman said like don't just
ask what the world needs ask what makes
you come alive
because what the world needs is more
people who have come alive
and e-commerce did not make me come
alive
and that's and that's when i made this
hard shift into into health
because for me like you know i grew up
in a household where my dad really
struggled with his health
he had his first triple bypass surgery
when he was in his 40s
and we we had to go through that journey
with him that to me
was the thing emotionally that sort of
made me come alive how do we take
some of the things that work for him and
make it available for more people
you hear this a lot somebody was
struggling a therapist helped them they
refound happiness and they devoted their
life to being a therapist so they can do
the same for others you know when
when somebody helps us we we know what
that feels like and we want to
do that for someone else and here you
are you lived in a household of
of emotional struggle watching your
father
go through these medical challenges and
you realize medicine's for me because
i've seen what the doctors have done for
my father
and that makes a lot of sense to me i
can't get off this because i'm trying to
understand it
you know that is it randomness that you
had a father who struggled with his
heart
and so you realize the value of medicine
and you and your brother
go into medicine if we keep our kids
hidden and covered in cotton wool
then it reduces the likelihood of those
opportunities
to be exposed to something that could
profoundly set them on a path
of purpose i wasn't expecting this
conversation to go so deep so quickly
but i mean were you take me simon is
is is a concept that i learned as a kid
which is which is dharma the best
interpretation of dharma in the english
language is that which sustains
it's this is this thing inside you that
you don't have to continue sort of
relighting over
and over again because it's just there
you know with the healthcare startup
that i ended up doing
it did fine it didn't knock it out of
the park
we ended up selling the company i had
mixed feelings about selling it because
again
not fantastic outcome not not unicorn by
any stretch of the imagination
and i'm at a healthcare conference a few
months later
and like there's this founder up on
stage and and he's got he's got the
company with all the rage
right like he's getting the articles
everybody's tuned into what he has to
say
and i'm just in the audience i'm not
even speaking at this conference i'm
just sitting in the audience
he doesn't even know i'm there and we
haven't ever met
but during q a somebody asks him like
what
motivated you to start this company well
tell me tell me about some of the things
that inspired you
and he said you know one of the
companies that i really looked at
carefully that inspired me
was a company called rise that was my
company
and i guess the the the lesson that that
taught me
was that like even if you don't reach
your intended destination
you still touch and teach people along
the way right you still end up having
this impact
and the question is are you truly here
like for the impact in that in that one
area
right is that is that truly the thing
that you want to sort of need on when i
ask people like what do they care about
they care about impact
i want to have impact on the world right
but i think we have to go more specific
than that
what exactly is that thing that whether
or not
your name is on the impact is it just
the same to you or is it is it is it
are they both wins because the answer
that is yes then
i think you're getting closer to your to
your dharma the way you describe dharma
i hear inspiration this flame that's lit
inside you that doesn't go out
but i think we're adding another layer
to this because i mean let's be honest
this is pretty multi-layered
which is the definition of success does
include
credit i think to give up credit is
selfless
and with fear of failure
comes a weird selfishness because let's
be honest it's about me
my failure versus my success i wonder
if we can teach young people
to endure failure when they learn
cooperation and teamwork first because
now
it's now no longer my failure it's about
us
it's about us yeah and it's not about
me getting credit it's about us having
an impact not me making an impact
because i think that's also
a twisted concept because when somebody
says i want to make an impact well news
flash
you're probably not going to do anything
by yourself
yeah i want to join a team that we can
make an impact i want to be a part of
something
that makes an impact is not only more
accurate it's also more attainable
versus going from job to job to job to
job and you and i have both seen this
saying i'm not making an impact i'm not
making an impact you're missing the
point you have the word i in there
when we think about creativity and
innovation we've been told that it's
sort of this two-step formula
you come up with a great idea and then
you execute on it really well
but i think what you're pointing out is
this is this hidden step in between
where it's not just you you've brought
in other people
it's early early colleagues early team
members early
early investors early partners that are
as
much part of this whole thing as as you
are and they feel
that level of ownership so that by the
time you actually reach execution stage
like it's a group of people who felt
like it was your idea it wasn't just the
person who came up with it in the first
place
i know of one of those unicorns
where when the company went gangbusters
and the founders became billionaires one
of them at least one of them i i only
know the story from one
made a long list and sent a bunch of
people
that had influenced him or somehow
believed in him for his entire life
he sent them a bunch of stock i love it
basically to say thank you you though
you not an investor
i wouldn't be where i am today if it
weren't for you in some way shape or
form whether you're a friend or a
teacher or whatever it was
and i think that humility and
recognizing that
i didn't do this alone is the thing
that's missing
and so i'm going to go back to your
class now which is
in your wonderful amazing incredible
class that you teach innovation
how do you teach teamwork i think we
teach teamwork through the idea of
dependence
right like knowing that you cannot
actually do this by yourself
and part of that is trying to get people
who
have different skill sets together and
knowing that there's going to be tension
there right because when you have a
hammer
everything looks like a nail and knowing
that your hammer
might not actually be the right way to
do this
is such an important part of i think the
practicalities of starting anything
and so we have students who are coming
together
but once coming from the point of view
of a med student who's been
shadowing doctors and inside the or
you have that person paired with an
attorney who sees risk everywhere he
looks
and now they're trying to sort of figure
out like how do we actually
create this new process for deep brain
stimulation with a new type of product
and realizing that neither of them have
the answers
so i think that i think that you teach
it just by
i think putting people together and
realizing that they
they are dependent on on one another
i tried that when i used to teach and
it didn't go as smoothly where we put
for the final project for my class and
it was a graduate level class
we made teams and they didn't get to
choose the teams we made the teams
and we told them that the team grade
will be your grade
and we had them prepare for something we
told them what the final project was and
in the day of final presentations we
changed one of the parameters
so they had to think on their feet and
work as a team
two things happened one the number of
complaints i got
it's not fair that we get this grade
because i did most the work
it's not fair that we get this grade
where you know blah blah blah wasn't
helping
that's unfair uh and just to take a
quick aside
the university would explain to us how
we're supposed to build teams you don't
take
all your best students and put one on
each and you take all your students and
put one on each team you don't evenly
distribute the teams
i took all my best students and put them
on one team and sort of like
and then like all my worst students and
put them on one team and then sort of
evenly distributed the others and when
i'm calling out the names of the
students you can hear them go
come on like i'm rigging the game and
i every year i taught not a single year
did the team of
of my best students come in first is
that right never
not a one because i think this is james
soreki's work
the team of geniuses care about
themselves more they only care about
their grades that's what motivates them
where the the more average kids because
they're more average
they have to work together and they make
better teams
and they actually outperform because
they actually look out for each other
and work together really really well and
we got very few complaints from those
teams and they were spectacular
it was always the teams of a type high
performers that were always
the most difficult pain in the ass and
they never came in first
you know the marine corps does what you
talk about
where when i had the opportunity to
visit paris island when i was riding
leaders eat last
which is marine boot camp one of the two
places that marines make marines
for the first two weeks the drill
instructor told me that these young
recruits
that all they'd run it to is work hard
and make put the spotlight on themselves
to prove that they
are strong enough to be marines that
they deserve to be here look at me i can
do this
and then after about two weeks weird
things start to happen because they
start putting them in situations to your
point
that they have to work together that
that you
physically are incapable of doing these
things alone that you're gonna have to
start relying on your team
and one of the interesting observations
is if you're one of the weak ones
the group automatically rejects you
if you're one of the strong ones who
thinks you don't need the team
the group automatically rejects you
just by like the anthropology of it
where the the cohesive unit will reject
the outsiders until they learn the
lesson
that you'll be fine if you contribute to
the group so the weaker ones learn
that if you contribute to the group the
group will look after you don't worry
and the strong ones learn to put their
egos aside and contribute to the group
and then slowly but surely they're
brought back into the fray
and i saw it play out at the end when
they go through something called the
crucible the competition where they have
to get through these crazy obstacles
quickly and i saw one of the young
recruits fall back
struggling and watch two of their
colleagues
turn around they know they're being
timed turn around go backwards
grab them by the webbing and drag them
and that's the thing they taught them
they taught them that the teamwork
and leaving no marine behind is more
important than coming in first
wow and and so the point is the marine
corps
does this and granted the stakes are
higher
and when it's life and death you know
the lessons are easier to to learn
but these young people who were
civilians when they came off the street
who were very selfishly driven when they
got there learned the value of teamwork
and so the question is is can't we teach
that in our high schools and our middle
schools and our business schools
especially in our business schools in
our medical schools
you know like the god complex among
surgeons for example
to put that aside maybe and recognize
that you keep a patient alive
because of the whole room of people not
just because of you and
your genius you know one of the things
that i think we tend to do when we walk
into a room especially for a
presentation
or a pitch or you know big meeting is we
tend to tell the story of me
right the story of my resume the story
of my idea the story of my vision
but i think that backable people these
people that i've been now studying for
the past few years and bringing their
stories into my classroom is
is is they tell the story of us right
how does my story
and your story come together to tell our
story
how is backable different than
self-promotion because i think it's
about
bringing people in it's about how do we
do this together
one of the most important concepts in
the book is this idea of flipping
outsiders into insiders
having other people feel ownership over
the idea that you've created
you know it comes it comes back to some
of the principles i know you know simon
like the ikea effect that we place up to
five times the amount of value
on something that we help build than
something that we simply buy off the
shelf
right because we we made it ourselves
the other story that i really love is in
the 1940s betty crocker
introduces instant cake mix right and
they and they think instant cake mix is
just going to be this huge mega best
seller
and then they're really surprised when
they find out that nobody is buying this
instant cake mix
and they can't figure out why and so
they hire this psychologist named ernest
decta
to go out into the field and start
interviewing customers
and daita comes back to the executives
of betty crocker and he says i think
that you have made the process of making
a cake
too easy too simple because you
basically remove
the customer from the creative process
and so dakta's recommendation is why
don't you remove
one ingredient and just see what happens
and so they do they remove the egg
so now as a customer to go out and you
have to buy an egg and you have to crack
and mix it in
and sales completely take off because
now when the cake comes out of the oven
people actually feel like they have
a sense of ownership over it yeah i have
a slightly different interpretation
on the betty crocker story which is they
have to do work
whenever i sort of want to quote-unquote
invite people in to use your to use your
terminology
i don't make it easy i did some work
with a company where we're inviting a
bunch of people to come join a class
with me
and you know the temptation is to make
it on an app click click click you know
are you available for the dates can you
do it what are your qualifications check
check check
inst you know instant gratification and
we made them write essays
and we actually read the essays and we
made them and so the people who phoned
it in we could tell and they got
rejected immediately
and the people who didn't feel like
writing an essay didn't apply
and the people who took the time to
actually write a proper essay to say why
they wanted to be in the course
those are the ones who got in we made
them do a little extra work now we don't
have to make it
very difficult but i'm a great believer
in putting in a few barriers so for
example
i co-host a leadership summit every year
and i do it from
thursday to saturday every year because
i don't want it to be a business trip
which is of the weekdays and i don't
want to be a boondoggle which is the
weekend
so i screw your week and your weekend so
you have to really want to be there
like a destination wedding right it's
like a destination wedding exactly do
you really love me
and and so i think the idea of of
requiring people to do some work this is
a perfect full circle of where we
started
over cuddling though instinctively is
the right attitude for a parent
which i agree you know we want to
protect our kids as best we can and give
them the best opportunities
etc every parent wants that but the
question is
are we denying them the joy of work
are we denying them the importance of
effort and this goes
not only to struggle like how are you
going to solve this problem like
you fell off the bicycle you have to get
back up but i think it's sometimes
something
not necessarily negative but asking
people to do a little more
you got to do a little work to feel
the joy of what you produce in other
words impact doesn't come free you can't
just go
buy a pair of toms shoes and feel like
you've done good in the world like it
doesn't work that way
and i think that's the parenting thing
we don't have to make all of the kids
refugees on
you know and teach themselves how to
read or be dropped off three miles from
home that's not what we're talking about
here
but if there's an opportunity for a kid
to put in a little extra effort
to get the thing they want like if you
save half
we'll match the other half and then you
can have the thing you want i think
there's a there there
and it gets me wondering perhaps the
innovation class that you teach
should also be taught to new parents
because that innovation thinking
and learning about risk and effort
is maybe more than starting a business
it's starting a child in a very
different path
every once in a while when i'm writing a
business book about
how to get other people to take a chance
on you in business right all of a sudden
i started to see these principles that
just like
this is life like this is this is
exactly
how i need to be a better parent to my
kids you know like for example one of
the things i found amongst
backable people is that they they really
tended to surround themselves with the
circle
like there were always a trusted circle
of people around them that they could go
to with ideas they could go to for
career advice
it really nurtured those relationships
backwall people did a really good job
with that more often than not and
you know around the time that i was
writing this book i ended up going to
the kingdom of bhutan
which bhutan is has always been
fascinating to me because they measure
progress in the country based on what
they call gross national happiness
so you know gdp and economic growth they
matter a lot but
they all feed up into this sort of
larger metric around the happiness of
their people
and when i was there i had a chance to
spend time with this research team and
this research team has been you know
they've been collecting this data now
for decades
and i asked him like when you're when
you're out there and you're talking to
people
is there a single question that you can
ask
that can give you a pretty good sense of
somebody's happiness
and they said yeah actually as a matter
of fact there is and the question is
if you were in real trouble right now
who could you call
and know with 100 certainty that person
would be there for you
and they believe people who have an
answer to that question are much more
likely to be happy
but there was a twist and the twist was
whose list are you on who can call you
and know with 100 certainty you are
going to be there for them
and they actually feel like if you have
an answer to that you have a higher
likelihood
of being happy so in other words it's
not a line it's it's a circle
right and it's this idea of a circle
that i think we can continue to come
back to you over and over and over again
so yeah i mean
these principles that we teach for these
sort of sometimes overly broad generic
topics like innovation
teach me how to act in life and on that
note
so nice to meet you really interesting
wonderful
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other